radical and very repugnant Republican uh
repugnant Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene appears to have
kicked a gun safety activist two times
and it's on video
um this is these are the people who say
we're against violence I guess I mean I
don't know it seems like they're against
it only in certain cases a congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green denies she kicked
an 18 year old political activist in an
incident caught on video in which it's
pretty damn clear that that's exactly
what she did Marjorie Taylor green was
walking uh behind gun rights activist
Mariana pakora Mariana pakora is holding
a phone recording and not once but twice
in this video
I see Marjorie Taylor green deliberately
looking down and appearing to kick
Mariana pakora this is an elected member
of Congress yes elected by lunatics but
that this is the United States of
America lunatics are allowed to elect
whoever they want and lunatics are
allowed to run and sometimes they elect
each other let's take a look at this
video see what you make of it and again
if you're just listening today I'll
describe it
okay so there's the first kick Marjorie
Taylor green kind of speeding up and you
can tell that she just she steps on her
or kicks her and then Mariana kind of
moves to her right and then it happens
again
[Music]
a second kick and of course it's all
under the guise of oh you're walking
right in front of me and so closely and
all of these different things oh it's
all an accident
you're blocking the congresswoman that's
why she kicked you twice
yeah so there's Marjorie Taylor green
and remember she is
um in favor of due process and she's in
favor of the rule of law uh she's for
Law and Order she's against violence and
yet you see that she very clearly kind
of speeds up in order to kick her on the
back of the leg
and kicks her two or three times this
woman is truly the lowest of the low it
looks like assault to me I hope Mariana
picara uh presses charges and
um initially there was a a camera angle
that made it seem potentially accidental
there really seems to be no question
here that it's intentional it's just a
question of can you actually demonstrate
that or show it for sure but think about
how far you know it's we've talked about
their allegations are actually
confessions oh the Democrats are going
to use voter fraud and try to steal an
election they don't win
to what Republicans did right and we
have dozens of such examples when here
it comes to this issue of we're against
violence but you should be able to talk
about anything you want remember they
love saying that on Twitter you should
be able to talk about whatever you want
and there should never you don't we
don't use physical uh uh accosting or
violence or we don't do that is
everybody should be allowed to talk and
say whatever they want free from
violence well here is a public Street
where an activist goes to Marjorie
Taylor green and asks a question about
the Second Amendment which is what they
claim we should all be able to do I mean
it's America after all and Marjorie
Taylor green kicks this woman at least
twice if not three times their
principles don't matter once they are
inconvenient and questions about the
Second Amendment
in these formats are inconvenient to
these Republicans and so this is the
outcome it's truly despicable I hope
charges are filed